propose sami ce que je te propose à
l'esam italien tomber l'ambiance je vais
dire on passe une interview moralité
d'accord allez vas-y mon interview
moralité sa mise
est-ce que vous avez déjà fouillé dans
le sac de votre mère non voilà bon c'est
pas moi c'est immoral de prendre voilà
ça marche et si la gonzesse à côté à la
marsa que j'aurais bien voulu
sami est ce que vous avez déjà copié sur
votre voisin à l'école
oui mais pourquoi tu dis ça je voulais
te réhabiliter mois d'affilée acteur
samy est ce que vous avez déjà triché à
l'examen oui mais moi j'ai dit la vérité
et je n'en suis pas ce que tu as déjà
menti un casting
ah oui je crois que même le principe non
monsieur je peux faire est ce que tu as
déjà abusé de sa célébrité pour draguer
une gonzesse jamais à jamais leur nom
j'avais les filles en ont abusé mais moi
j'en ai jamais
sami est ce que tu as déjà insulté un
plombier mais jamais à l'étiage essayer
ce need a déjà eu recours à l'amour
tarifé l'amour tarifé en français dans
le texte ça veut dire quoi
les [ __ ] à l'epu jay parini rue saint
denis alors j'ai grandi là bas
et voilà sami est ce que des faits déjà
eu recours à une substance illicite
jamais moi je trouve pas dans le jardin
tout ça moi je vois des renard quand je
fume donc c'est pas la peine
voilà je veux dire voilà non bâti les
fouilles j'ai soulevé ça peut être coupé
dans le truc pour cela mais a minima est
ce que tu as dit est ce que tu as menti
pendant cette interview cela peut
arriver
tu as déjà pratiqué des orgies par tous
n'ont jamais vraiment tout à l'heure une
fois quoi maintenant elle révéla quoi
est ce que tu as déjà fait des partouzes
il dit non et publics et ou alors vous
passer mon temps à partouzes irrigation
ne m'oblige pas à sortir la fiche que
j'ai pas sorti tout allait bien je ne
ferais ça me je vois vraiment que vous
êtes un être extrêmement respectable et
je suis content voyez qu'on ne fait pas
que votre procès quand vous venez dans
cette émission ont essayé de vous
réhabilités chaque fois tu mens glisse
une petite quand même et ses chiens dans
les jambes à la tiens un truc voilà je
vous l'avais jamais fait est-ce que vous
avez déjà insulté une hôtesse de l'air
sur le vol paris canada paris toronto
ouais non
je vous avais déjà aidé une vieille dame
a traversé la rue pour lui pas pour lui
piquer son sac
non non pour l'aider à traverser le
caveau non plus cela elle voulait pas
les lieux de côté admis ce que vous avez
déjà détruit la gueule le paparazzi
italiens l'île maurice j'ai défoncé sa
gueule
reffle harper l'a alors l'art fait tu
dis non non jamais c'est pas vrai bon
laquelle on garde au montage les enfants
et il méritait américain où la première
voilà on va garder les deux au montage
bien alors ça me paraissait beaucoup
plus grave
est-ce que vous avez déjà regardé tf1 le
samedi soir oui comme tout le monde les
matchs de football
il leur côté quand même il est corporate
gaccio est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté
une dose d'héroïne s'emballe jamais j'ai
été relaxé d'ailleurs jours pour cette 2
0 à ce que le juge a dit ça vaut pas
cent balles donc ton ami c'est mon ami
szpiner qui m'a défendu et qui va
enchaîner laurent lahaxe un super avocat
j'ai brûlé jamais autant prendre un bon
a surtout quand ils sont sur ta gueule
je pense que j'ai écrits vains et vaut
mieux oui
non là celle-là on l'a déjà fait la tête
jamie en bouillie trois polonais ou c
mais il méritait immérité pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient fait on fait
des queues de poisson ils m'ont embouti
ma voiture
j'avais ma copine qui pleurait à côté de
moi s'est il mérite une gifle ou deux
j'ai payé j'ai payé 3 3 polonais je
faisais des fonds c'est bien peu et du
coup bas après tout le résultat parce
que tu l'a annoncé tout à l'heure voilà
ça s'est bien terminé
ça c'est bien bien tard me voilà donc
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire que t'as pas
trop de moralité mais que tu as un bon
avocat
ouais on peut dire ça mais j'ai
d'amoralité quand même même si peu soit
que jamais lui dans le sac de ta mère
jamais c'est bien thème ta mère je la
nord c'est l'essentiel
le droit d'ériger le taxi dans le même